in my lifetime women have gone from the
kitchen to the boardroom people of color
from the wood shed to the White House
gay people from the closet to the altar
every culture is a unique answer to a
fundamental question what does it mean
to be human and alive because the
greatest curse in the history of
humanity a curse it goes back to the
dawn of awareness his cultural myopia
the idea that my world is a real world
and everybody else has a failed attempt
at being me my point is a cultural
myopia not just a curse of humanity but
it's of one horrific trait of humanity
that in a multicultural in plural istic
interconnected world we can no longer
indulge as if literally all of the glory
of the rainforests and and and the
natural wealth the natural capital of
the forest was just sort of being put
into a grinder and ground out to produce
money you know let me ask you a question
what's a formula photosynthesis carbon
dioxide and water sparked by photons of
light creates carbohydrate and releases
oxygen but you could easily graduate not
just from this undergraduate university
but from law school from business school
without knowing what the formula of life
yeah something just think of it I mean
half the language of the world that were
spoken the day you were born are not
being taught to children which means
they're on the road extinction to lose
half the language and generation is to
literally lose half of humanity's
collective knowledge every fortnight
some elder passes away and carries with
them in the grave the last syllables of
mangement
you know if God's all-powerful why does
he allow evil to exist in the universe
but when Krishna said to thicken the
plot but I took psychedelics and I'm
proud to say that I wouldn't write the
way I write I would think they were I
think likewise I wouldn't have
understood the nature of cultural
relativism as an anthropologist I
wouldn't treat women the way I do our
parents used to say don't take these
things you'll never come back the same
that was a whole bloody point right so
that the fact that the genies out of the
bottle ain't going back and the tsunami
of social change and transformation and
spiritual growth and reinvention of our
entire sense of ourselves in the planet
it's rolling forward and you know get
out of the way if you're not prepared
because you've got it'll drown you if
you're not prepared to float upon it
know someone's opinion may contradict
yours way my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we if what is
the nature of this reality hello
everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sathyan we are on
site at the University of British
Columbia at the anthropology and
sociology building in the beautiful
Vancouver British Columbia we are now
going to be speaking with dr. Wade Davis
hi Wade yeah how are you thank you so
much for coming out my pleasure it's an
honor I'm so excited for this Sweden I'm
so so pumped for those who don't know
awaits background he is a world-renowned
anthropologist and ethno botanist
focused on worldwide indigenous cultures
and psychoactive plants he's a multiple
time award-winning author filmmaker
photographer former National Geographic
explorer-in-residence professor of
anthropology and BC leadership chair in
cultures and ecosystems at risk at the
University of British Columbia his work
has taken him from the Amazon to the
Arctic from Africa to Polynesia he is a
member of the Order of Canada and
recently became an honorary Colombian
citizen you can find his links
by Oh Davis wait calm as well as this
Instagram page alright wait we're gonna
start off with our very big picture
questions that we love asking our guests
the first one is are we really all one I
mean that is a big question but I would
say Allen if you think about it
there have been two moments of
illumination in our lifetimes that will
be spoken about 10,000 years hence one
famously occurred on Christmas Eve 1968
when Apollo went around the dark side of
the moon and for the first time in human
history we saw not a sunrise or a
moonrise but an earth rise and suddenly
this idea that we're on a flat infinite
horizon was replaced by this rather
haunting image of a blue planet as the
astronauts so beautifully put it
floating in a velvet void of space and
that really sparked a wave of
illumination that we can sense around
the world I mean when I was a kid just
getting people to stop throwing garbage
out of a car window was an environmental
victory nobody spoke about biodiversity
of the biosphere now these are terms
used by by children you know no country
had a Ministry of the Environment now
everyone does effective or not they have
one and and at a more profound level it
precipitated a wave of change a kind of
paradigm shift the full dimensions of
which are difficult to identify but I do
know this in my lifetime women have gone
from the kitchen to the boardroom people
of color from the wood shed to the White
House gay people from the closet to the
altar what is not to like about a world
capable of such social reinvention now
the second great point of illumination
also occurred at the end of a long
journey but not a journey into space
but into the very fiber of our being
and over the course of the last
generation geneticists have finally
proven it to be true
something that philosophers have always
hoped to be true and that is the fact
that there were all brothers and sisters
and I don't mean that in the spirit of
hippie ethnography I mean quite
literally studies of the human genome in
the last generation as shown no doubt
whatsoever that the genetic endowment of
humanity is a continuum race has been
exposed as an author of fiction we're
all cut from the same genetic cloth we
are all in fact descendants of that same
handful of people who walked out of
Africa some 65,000 70,000 years ago and
embarked on this extraordinary Hegira
a journey 40,000 years in duration
roughly 2500 human generations had
carried the human spirit to every corner
of the habitable habitable world
but here's the important revelation if
you accept that scientific truth it
means that by definition all human
populations share the same raw genius
the same mental acuity the same basic
human potential and critically whether
that human genius is invested in
technological wizardry which has been
the great achievement of the West or
placed instead into the complex task of
unraveling the mystic threads of memory
inherent in a myth is simply a matter of
choice and cultural orientation there is
no hierarchy in the affairs of culture
of the old Victorian idea that we
somehow went from the savage to the
Barbarian to the civilized of the Strand
of London know that European society
stood at the apex of a pyramid that
sloped down to the so called primitives
of the world has been absolutely
debunked by modern science and reduced
to an element of the 19th century as
distant from our lives and and as
irrelevant to our lives as the old
colonial conceit
or the old religious idea that the earth
was but 6,000 years old in the stunning
affirmation of the connectedness of
humanity science has come to the fore to
prove the truth of the central
revelation of anthropology the scent
revelation of Franz Boas the idea that
the other peoples of the world aren't
failed attempts of being you they're not
failed attempts of being modern every
culture is a unique answer to a
fundamental question what does it mean
to be human and alive and the peoples of
the world answer that they do so in
7,000 different languages those
languages and those answers become our
collective human repertoire for dealing
with the challenges that will confront
us in the coming centuries every culture
has something to say
each deserves to be heard just as none
has monopoly on the route to the divine
and we often we often think of you know
if you want to think of the individual
streams of thought that cracked open the
European mind in the lifetime of our
great-grandparents you know you had
Darwin showing that species were mutable
you had Einstein showing that an apple
doesn't fall from the tree quite as
Newton thought it did you had Freud
suggesting that we don't even control
the sanctity of our own thoughts but the
fourth and the individual who in many
ways was more important than all those
guys at least from my point of view was
Franz Boas because Franz Boas recognized
that there was no hierarchy that every
culture had something to say each voice
was important and that every culture was
a product of its own history and
adaptive choices and and that is so
important because the greatest curse in
the history of humanity a curse that
goes back to the dawn of awareness is
cultural myopia the idea that my world
is a real world and everybody else has a
failed attempt at being me and and you
know many societies the United States
amongst them you know are often accused
of being culturally myopic in that sense
but it's almost unfair because every
culture is I mean most indigenous people
you translate the name for themselves
and it comes out the people the
implication being that the blokes beyond
the horizon or savages beyond the pale
the word barbarian comes from the Greek
word barbarous one who babbles if he
didn't speak Greek you didn't exist when
Herodotus famously came back 400 years
before the Christian era having traveled
to the ends of the known world and had
the audacity to say in Athens that there
was actually something going on there of
interest in that Persian court Plato
wanted him eliminated killed if not
killed exiled for having the audacity to
say that something interesting could go
on anywhere in the world that was not
within the the splendor of Greece right
and but the Aztek had the same thing in
the wattle you know the you know so my
point is a culture of myopia not just a
curse of humanity but it's of one
horrific trade of humanity that in a
multicultural in clurel istic
interconnected world we can no longer
indulge an anthropology is the antidote
to cultural myopia anthropology is the
antidote to nativism anthropology is the
antidote to Donald Trump
I really appreciated you bringing up to
start this profound moment of the earth
rise in this understanding of the
beautiful green and blue marble here
that we share with the other 10 million
species all the biodiversity here and
how the awakening to the stewardship
being so critical and then also the idea
of the progress that we've been making
and the amount of ethics that have been
evolving morals and philosophies that
have been evolving over time to lead us
towards a more just world and then how
if we will be evolving our technologies
to be able to really experience embody
the wisdoms
of true interconnectedness and true
unconditional love true presence as we
do build these general intelligences and
as we enter into that hockey sticking
exponential technology age and then
furthermore you bring up the 7,000
languages that are here in your and your
avidly talking about how the human gets
to express itself so beautifully the
consciousness and spirit expresses
itself through all of these beautiful
cultures and languages and that we are
going through a process of the
condensation of culture of language to
the degree at which it's so rapid that
so many people in the world are learning
English learning Mandarin and the in a
sense these are some of these languages
are not being taught you say about half
or so 3,500 of them not being taught to
children and there are projects that the
Rosetta project that are trying to log
them and we are trying to at least
retain them of an archaeological record
a catalogue of them which is very
beautiful yet to be able to find what
are the profound ways of seeing the
world of being human through those
languages and ways of experiencing the
world and the spirit expressing itself
and being able to find what could
potentially be the best like you said
there's no monopoly on the path to the
divine onry communing with the divine I
love that that phrasing so to live in a
pluralistic to live in a coexisting way
of enabling all people to reach the
divine and also to make it so that all
people get to express their own unique
gifts into the world the Divine's
already right here in us all around us
and to awaken to that and to build the
social fabric that's conducive to people
figuring that out and also to unleashing
their gift
into the world is paramount and I want
to see if maybe you think this is true
then that is the is then the root the
most upstream issue that we face that we
have forgotten that interconnectedness
that we've put that to the side that we
have separate well you know every
culture Franz Boas would say as a
product fits history and his choices and
we're no exception
you know I I wrote a book called the
wayfinders and I've editor put a snappy
title on why ancient wisdom matters in
the modern world forcing me to answer
that question and I did so implicitly in
the book but I did so explicitly at the
end of the book in through two words
climate change
and what I meant by that is that we
forget that climate change may have
become humanity's problem but it wasn't
caused by humanity it was caused by a
very narrow subset of humanity with a
particular ideology and worldview that
for the last 400 years have been
stealing the ancient sunlight of the
world and and the the reason that these
other voices of humanity matter these
other ways of being the evidence of
alternative visions of life itself in in
one small measure they're they're
essential because they remind us that
our way is not the only way and they put
the lie to those of us within our own
society who say that we cannot change as
we know we all must change a fundamental
way we inhabit this planet so what is it
about this Western idea that brought us
to this point well you can trace it in
our own history you know during I go
back to Aristotle but even if you just
go back to the Enlightenment when
Descartes said that all that existed was
mind and matter in a single gesture he D
animated the world and part of that was
our desperate attempt to escape the
tyranny of absolute faith right and and
and to allow the mind of man as it was
put at the time to triumph over notions
of myth magic mysticism and so on but we
also swept away all notions of metaphor
and and and in a single
we D animated the world and as Saul
Bellow would eventually say science
would make a housecleaning of belief and
if phenomena can be measured
they couldn't exist and the idea that
the flight of a bird could have meaning
was dismissed as ridiculous and
ridiculed but we forget that metaphor is
what actually drives human relationships
of the natural world for most of our
history what do I mean by metaphor if
you Alan are raised in California to
believe that a mountain is a pile of
rock ready to be mined you're gonna have
a different relationship to it than if
you're my godson on the mountains of
Peru raised to believe that a mountain
is an ape hoodia T that will direct his
or her destiny the issue isn't who's
right and who's wrong it's how the
belief system mediates the relationship
between the natural landmark in the case
of a mountain and the aspirations of
human beings I was raised in these
forests of British Columbia to believe
that they existed to be cut that was a
foundation of the ideology of scientific
forestry that I learned at this
university and practice in the forests
of British Columbia as a logger for a
long time that made me fundamentally
different than my friends amongst the
Haida than a child at the equal walk
walk who believed that the forests of
the abode of deities who kook and the
crooked beak of heaven and the cannibal
spirits that would be threatening the
homicide initiate now the interesting
thing isn't who's right who's wrong is
this forest outside this window just
cellulose and board feet
is it the domain of the spirits the
interesting thing is the metaphor in
other words if you believe it's just
cellulose and board feet you're going to
treat it appropriately which is why my
tradition my way of thinking inherited
from my father about these forests has
led to them being torn asunder in three
generations whereas my friends amongst
the first nations their story as told to
them by their elders allowed them to
have a very modest ecological footprint
because of their beliefs and the beliefs
meaning is so it's not about whether
these beliefs are true or not it's it's
a
sequences of the beliefs now now in our
society once we D animated the world all
other sentient beings became just sort
of props on a theater set upon which the
human drama unfolded that's not how most
societies around the world view other
life forms most other societies again
mediated by the notion of metaphor or
have very strong sense of reciprocity
with the natural world whereby human
beings are not seen as part of the
problem as we do but rather the only
solution because it's only through the
human imagination that the desires of
the divinity can come through I mean the
Kogi and the Arawak owes the elder
brothers the descendants of the ancient
tyrona civilization who to this day in
the Sierra Nevada they sent to Martin
Colombia the highest coastal mountain
range on earth they remain ruled by
ritual priesthood in the and and and the
society truly maintains and believes
that their prayers and rituals literally
maintained the cosmic balance of the
world you find this in the southern
Andes where where every gesture from
economic exchange to spiritual exchange
to to politics is mediated by
reciprocity you see it in the northwest
Amazon where the but asana and the
mucuna really do believe that plants are
just people in another dimension of
reality you see it in the Athabaskan
peoples of northern Canada in the boreal
forests who literally believe that human
beings were were taught by the animals
and the animals were taught by human
beings you see it in the High Arctic
amongst the Inuit who believed that that
if a animal is not treated properly it
will not allow itself to be hunt but if
animals are not hunted they too will
suffer again these ideas of reciprocity
you see it in the outback of Australia
in the way that a kangaroo killed by a
hunter is rich realistically prepared
before it is gutted you see
you know in the High Arctic you you know
a hunter of a seal if he does not drip
fresh water into the mouth of a dead
seal he will never get another one so
the point is you have all these
wonderful gestures that are gestures of
reciprocity
I mean hunting myths as Joseph Campbell
famously said you know our expressions
of a covenant between the hunter and the
prey between predator and prey and a way
of hunting societies rationalizing the
terrible fact that to live they have to
kill the thing they love most which is
the animals upon which they depend I
mean I work four years learning
mythology from an old get sound elder in
northern British Columbia and he spoke
English as a sixth language
and it was really interesting to pay
attention to how what his choice of
language you know which is always a case
of someone speaking a foreign tongue and
he would never say for example we must
never hurt animals because the hunter by
definition has to kill the prey upon
which his life depends Alec would always
say you must not suffer an animal you
use that verb because suffers something
else that involves dominance humiliation
cruelty sad ism right and and so most of
most of the world's populations have
been motivated by some kind of sense of
reciprocity doesn't mean that people
around the world are kind of ecological
natives or that they haven't had an
impact on their environment of course
they have but this kind of scale of
industrialized consumption of the planet
as if literally all of the glory of the
rainforests and and and the natural
wealth the natural capital of the forest
was just sort of being put into a
grinder and ground out to produce money
you know this is a uniquely modern
phenomenon and if we look around the
world for example
[Music]
it's very poignant and very moving that
indigenous people who played no role
whatsoever in the creation of the
problem of climate change are not only
the ones suffering the most from it and
the implications of it but are also in
their own way doing more dramatically
addressing it I'll give you an example
in the southern mountains of the Andes
there's a fantastic syncretic ritual
pilgrimage that we know existed for
hundreds if not thousands of years
before the arrival of the Spaniards and
it's called the Khoya DT that stars Snow
Festival and once each year and of
course with the arrival of the Spanish
like so many of those rituals it was
co-opted by the Catholic Church and now
it's kind of a perfect expression of the
fusion of the two faiths 500 years of
Catholic belief and pre-columbian ideas
that is a complete amalgam of the Andes
today I mean I once asked a friend of
mine who's from one of the communities
outside of Cusco which she felt when
anthropologist tried to separate what
was pre-columbian from what was Catholic
she said it just gives us a headache
because it's a fusion but today so the
the pilgrimage has all kinds of
Christian elements to it you carry the
crosses of your communities up to the
sacred valley pass the Stations of the
Cross right out of the Bible but you're
in the shadow of Austin Gotti the most
sacred mountain of the Inca and then the
crosses are carried by the public those
who are symbols of the of the kind of
the wild heart of humanity but also the
source of order for Humanity the carrion
of the glaciers implanted for two days
and two nights to absorb the power and
energy of Pachamama
and then they're carried back to the
community reinvigorated for in coming
year there's a classic sort of
pre-columbian Andean ritual and and and
the penultimate stage of that pilgrimage
was always to shipped small blocks of
ice from the glaciers to carry back to
the community to kind of complete the
cycle of the divine but also to allow
those elderly and frail in the community
- unable to travel or to climb to
participate in the in the collective
ritual now witnessing the incredible
recession of those glaciers the people
have felt that they had to do something
about it
and so they've unilaterally ceased the
taking of those trivial bits of ice from
the glaciers now that points out
something really important for us
climate change and it's repercussions
is sort of a you know it's it's a
scientific debate some people maintain
or it's a political debate certainly you
know it's a technical challenge it's an
economic opportunity whatever you want
to say of it but for those who really
believe that they're responsible for the
well-being of the earth it is a profound
psychological and existential crisis
because it's their fault if the earth is
not doing well and so one of the things
iíve noticed in my own travels is that
from the deserts of Australia to the
High Arctic where you know I've in
places like conic and North West
Greenland the highest community and Paul
both northerly community in the world
where the ice used to come in September
and state of July now it comes in in
November and has gone by March the whole
world is melting from beneath the people
and everywhere in the Andes were and in
Tibet where they're seen glacial
recession there's this kind of upsurge
of ritual activity as people by the
terms of reference of their own
societies they're actually trying to do
something about the problem investing
their time and energy and their faith
and their hopes and their dreams in a
way that puts us to shame and it's very
tragic and it's very poignant because of
course we're the ones responsible for
the Kotak you know imminent catastrophe
we should go to the language I just let
me this role you know there's so many
points though that I want to address it
with what you said and then hit it back
just that you gave this beautiful idea
about if you believe that if you pass
down if you pass down to your children
when they're birthed into the world the
idea that the air that you breathe in
comes from phytoplankton and trees
breathing out and if you pass them that
instead of and and things like when you
take a bite out of the Apple it's
powered by the Sun versus just
exchanging the sheet of paper for the
Apple at the store and not knowing
anything else about this whole intricate
let me ask your questions let me ask you
a question what's the formula
photosynthesis well I know the krebs
cycle is really important but notice the
world chlorophyll is what enables four
parts of this is very hard we should
know I know it's like I I'm not being
provocative or in any way dismissive at
all Island I'm just you know it's just
that's a problem isn't it you're right I
mean I mean if photosynthesis is just
the idea that carbon dioxide and water
sparked by photons of light creates
carbohydrate and releases oxygen
simple as that simple as that simple as
that yeah now now one person in a
million knows that formula and that's
why I was sort of teasing you with that
right yeah we let's go through this one
more time it's that important you're
absolutely right yes so photosynthesis
photosynthesis is just this miracle
whereby plants can eat light and all
that really what it means is a carbon
carbon dioxide comes together with water
spark by photons of light to produce
carbohydrate food or an and releasing
oxygen oxygen right and my point is is
is that you know searly co2 Plus water
water photons of light creates
carbohydrates car rides for food for the
plant
yeah and food for us and food for us and
when we eat it yeah and then it sparks
ox
oxygen which oxide creates the
environment upon which we breathe right
yeah
it small so interconnect because that's
the breath cycle the air cycle but also
the nutrition cycle yeah but I mean just
you just focus for on the science you
know in other words in other words
sometimes we can spin this stuff off
into flowery things that forget how just
basic now obviously photosynthesis is
it's much more complicated than that in
terms of the pathways and so on but my
point is that here's a university this
University of British Columbia is ranked
I think 37th in the world but take any
university major university any universe
any high school you you could you could
not possibly graduate from this
university if you didn't know the
difference between a poem and a work of
prose if you didn't know the difference
between a photograph and a painting if
you you know if you if you if you didn't
know the difference between a verb and a
noun but you could easily graduate not
just from this undergraduate University
but from law school from business school
without knowing the formula of life and
how can you you know a friend of mine
here an old wonderful environmentalist
Paul George a hero of British Columbia
once said to me no I said how do we get
people to appreciate nature more he said
he said they simply get them into it you
know how do we get people how can we
possibly get people to understand the
profundity of biological relationships
and profundity of ecological connections
the the interdependence of life itself
if they are utterly scientifically
illiterate if you're allowed to go
through university without ever studying
biology and I say that as someone who is
Lee could have done it you know I if we
pass all our time in a concrete jungle
right no no no it's not about that
it's not about the concrete jungle it's
about the pedagogy's of our institutions
of learning you are not allowed to
graduate from college if you can't read
and write correct you know you can't
you're not allowed to you know but we
accept that someone can be fully
educated who has not the slightest idea
of anything to do with biology
think about that
and Gary Snyder the poet once said to me
of course the only two things worth
studying our biology and anthropology so
so you know III think you know how can
we expect I mean we're not I'm and I'm
not talking about people who are
unfortunate enough not to even finish
high school or not even to have a dream
of going to college I mean that that
that's a whole nother issue that the
society has to confront I'm talking
among the high most highly educated
people have gone to Yale Princeton
Stanford you know that are now sitting
in Congress people in Silicon Valley how
many how many people in Silicon Valley
how many people running these companies
that have two billion eyeballs that they
work with every day can you know I'm not
saying you couldn't but I mean my point
is not to be be judgmental it's just
that I know I I went off to college and
I never studied biology in high school I
I went through two and a half years at
Harvard he never had to study biology
and I just happen to go to the Amazon
and fall in love with plants yeah and
you mentioned the krebs cycle well the
night I I came back from the Amazon
after 15 months in that first adjourn so
completely fascinated by botany that
that's all I studied and on the night
that I understood the krebs cycle I was
thrown out of the science library at
Harvard for making so much noise I was
racing like a like an idiot from table
to table disturbing other students as
they studied Chaucer or something or
whatever they're studying did you know
did you know this you know I was just
like I was like on a kind of a yeah
psychotic high yeah yeah aluminum boy
and and and
my point is again not to be judgmental
but you know we we forget how just
amazingly scientifically illiterate we
are and and when you think of for
example notions of the flow of water and
the significance of water that people
like the mammals of the Kogi have all of
their ideas which are so Baroque
Byzantine in their complexity actually
are remarkably reflective of exactly
what we know about water I mean how many
people know that water is never created
or nor destroyed the water thats lakes
your thirst today is the same water that
satisfied the needs of the dinosaurs
right you know water only beads up
because of a the oxygen atoms around the
surface that's why a tear can flow
that's why woman's blood can flow that's
why we are all part of the hydrological
cycle squeeze down your body extract the
sinew and the cartilage and and a bit of
bone and you would flow as readily to
the ocean as a river you know and so to
me getting people to understand the the
brilliance of life itself we now
understand for example in you if you
walked out of this office and and walked
in front of that tree your footstep
would be on top of 300 miles of my cilia
one footstep one boot one shoe would be
standing on 300 miles of my cilia you
know fungal filaments that are the the
nerve center they the Nexus the Internet
if you will of the northwest coast
forests we now know that these there's
research going on at this university by
this fantastic woman showing that trees
communicate amongst each other that that
that a mother tree will differentially
direct nutrients through it the
the the symbiotic relationship on with
those fungal micro Rosie deliberately
putting more nutrients into a seedling
from herself secondarily to a seedling
from the same species and to in a
tertiary way to other denizens of the
force I mean these miracles of
biological relation that that professor
Seymour has figured out are simply
mind-blowing and and and so the point is
we can't be mechanic and that's why I
come down harshly on the fuzzy language
of the new age or you know like you know
we have to be precise in our language we
can't just invoke kind of you know
phantasmagoric fantasies you know
because the truth is so much better and
the truth is revealed by science and you
know and that's you know when we and I
think that you know the PERT there one
of the things about anthropology is that
it you know I remember once I was in the
orinoco delta with Winnie kina waddle
with a friend of mine Werner Wilbert
whose dad was also an anthropologist and
and and Werner was an anthropologist and
we just we paddled the dugout past a
grave of a shaman and I just remember
Werner said to me you know Don Antonio
taught my father to look beneath the
surface of things and that's what
anthropology does and and so if we think
of language you know one of the things
that maybe just before we get there
there's so many things to just still
unpack and I know we're gonna get to
that there was this dis understanding of
it's not only that the air that I
breathe in frozen fighter plane trees
and the way that I bite the Apple is
powered by the Sun but it's also
understanding the science being
scientifically literate furthermore is
you give this idea that that as we have
progressed it's been millions of years
of human evolution and then agrarian
time start about 10,000 ish years ago
and the
these brand new industrial times are
only a couple hundred years old and
we're piling in this process of billions
of people into metropolis and building
the exponential technology age we're
piling all of civilizations answers we
think are coming from just the last
couple hundred years and all of the
immediate return hunter-gathering all of
the agrarian all of this these millions
of years we're not necessarily looking
for understanding how to harmoniously
live in an interconnected way with each
other and the other ten million species
in this biosphere and be good stewards
there's that and then this last part
that you got to it that's so important
is that when you take a look at the ways
that trees sequester carbon and then and
then distribute them amongst their
amongst them roots plus mycelium
networks two trees that need it more
than they do that similar style process
can actually be apply to wealth
inequality today that if you're going
out and purchasing you know 50 out of 50
are this plane etc with house that
there's plenty of ways to distribute the
excess disposable income to other
artists entrepreneurs spiritual leaders
just building a better social fabric
that ends conducive to people unleashing
their gifts around the world that just
requires that understanding like you
said it's a it's a process of scientific
literacy it's a process of understanding
these most fundamental ways that we are
interconnected interdependent and become
better stewards of that said processor
you gave this point again that it's
actually the most upstream issue is the
pedagogy that we that we teach that the
pedagogical processes of bringing our
children into the world and then what
they learn is the most upstream issue
and the design of the fabric that we
live in
being towards that stewardship I'm a
huge huge proponent of understanding
that most upstream issue and then next I
feel like is understanding the purpose I
mean the the purpose it seems of this
reality what does it seem like to you
after doing all of your work in the last
several decades what does it seem like
it's the point of all this well I'm you
know let me let me just address your
issue of nomads and you know if you were
to take the most leave you know 300
thousand years since we've sort of been
a identifiable species or so you know
from Homo erectus and and and made it a
kind of a 24-hour clock agriculture
doesn't come in till 11:54 p.m. yeah so
for most of our history we were
Wanderers
you know nomads on a pristine planet and
nomadic societies are really profoundly
different I mean how do you measure
wealth in a community where there's no
incentive to accumulate anything now
nomadic societies doesn't mean they just
wandered you know from space to space
indifferently no nomads nomadic people
almost unbearably live in time-honored
territories where their movement is
seasonal between known features in a
landscape which could be everything from
a sacred space to a particular resource
a clasp of sago palm or whatever but the
bottom line is that societies that have
to keep on the move
I have no incentive to accumulate
anything so if you think of a group like
the command of Southeast Asia of Sarawak
and Malaysia
their literal definition of wealth is
the strength of social relations between
people they there's no word for thank
you in their language because Sharon is
a reflexive
act they really do live by the adage of
the poor man shames us all when when
several per man came to Vancouver in the
late 1980s as part of this effort we had
to sort of draw attention to the
destruction of their rainforest homeland
nothing
impressed them in Vancouver whatsoever
even though not one of the three had
been outside of the forest really
nothing impressed them in Vancouver save
homelessness they just could not Rock a
place of such abundance could allow such
scarcity and again back to this sort of
you know the this this kind of myth
making in the West that that that life
has been a constant Volusia nari kind of
set of social improvements right with
agriculture being identified as the
great you know advance well you can
build an argument quite to the contrary
that agriculture was a greatest disaster
ever to befall humanity in the sense
that you know we talked about the
Neolithic Revolution well it wasn't a
revolution it was just a gradual shift
but what did that actually bring us it
brought us into close proximity
animal domestication it brought us into
close proximity with animals and every
major disease we have from smallpox to
AIDS was vectored into our population by
that close proximity with animals going
back to lord knows how long for smallpox
but I mean polio is more recent
you know AIDS is 1959 nutrition dropped
dramatically if we look at the the
statute of Paleolithic individuals in a
place like Greece or turkey it took them
till deep into the 20th century for a
modern man to catch up because generally
agriculture implied heavy dependence on
a handful of grasses you know
we'd rice millet you know whatever that
were high in carbohydrate not high in
protein and we're highly susceptible to
to disease and to drought and to crop
failure and and therefore famine became
an issue and of course agriculture did
create surplus so surplus wasn't
necessary for high civilization as we've
seen on the Pacific Northwest of North
America where the salmon the you look in
the red cedar allowed for civilization
in the absence of the cult of the seed
but with so-called surplus for the most
part also came hierarchy power
exploitation and so many things so I'm
not I'm not arguing against agriculture
but but it it just happened but the idea
that it was this fantastic advance is
not so clear you know we have this idea
of the of the gentle farmer in the Glen
you know nurturing his his or her land
well the truth is the nomadic people
were the ones who really looked after
the natural world and agriculture if you
think about it has been an ongoing
spreading cancer since its inception
that it's consumed wild spaces of the
planet again I'm not judging it's just
what happened so I think again it gets
back to this idea of looking beneath the
surface of things not to say that we
should all give up on agriculture
no-one's talking about going to a
pre-industrial past but again when we
the reason the stuff becomes important
is that when you have so nation states
like Malaysia being embarrassed by the
nomadic Penang and and and seen there in
culturation as being for the good of
everybody involved when really what it
is is an excuse to get indigenous people
off of landscapes to open up resource
exploitation on lands where they have
lived for a long time and Lance upon
which their presence is an impediment to
those industrial industrial developments
that's really what the whole
development is an old development
paradigm is is is questionable I mean
genocide the physical extermination of
the people is universally condemned
ethnocide the destruction of a people's
way of life is not only not condemned
it's embraced in many quarters as
appropriate development policy no
pastoral nomads or or hunters and
gathers don't fit the image of the
nation-state and therefore they have to
be eliminated right and that that
process is is something that is is
current around the world I mean there's
a fire burning over the earth taking
with it cultures and languages and and
again the biological analogy is apropos
an extinction is a natural phenomena in
nature but but in general over the last
six hundred million years speciation the
creation of new forms of life has
outpaced extinction creating a more
diverse place and the biodiversity
crisis were seen today is an aberration
and anomaly and a horrific moment in
time by the same token languages have
come and gone through history we don't
speak Babylonian anymore Assyrian we
don't speak Latin in the streets of Rome
but critically these languages slipped
away at a pace which allowed them to
leave descendants in the case of Latin
the Romance languages of Europe now
languages like species are being
eradicated at a pace I wish they haven't
a chance to leave descendents I mean
just think of it I mean half the
languages of the world that were spoken
the day you were born are not being
taught to children which means they're
on the road to extinction
now it's really important to recognize
that a language is not just vocabulary
or grammar a language is a flash to the
human spirit it's a vehicle through
which the soul of each particular
culture comes in the material world
every language is an old-growth forest
of the mind of water should have thought
an ecosystem of social spiritual
psychological ecological possibilities
and to lose half the languages in
generation is to literally lose half a
humanities
collective knowledge because the
importance of a language is not a
correlate of the number of people who
speak it the importance of a language is
the fact that by definition it is a
branch of the human tree that goes back
for multiple generations yes and there
many people who said wouldn't the world
be a better place if we all spoke one or
two languages wouldn't communication
being facilitated and my answer to that
is to always say what a great idea but
let's make that universal language in up
the duck let's make it catch well let's
make it Haida let's make it look all
done and so on and you suddenly begin to
feel as a native speaker of English what
it'd be like to be enveloped in silence
to have no means or ability to pass on
the wisdom of your ancestry or to
anticipate the promise of your
descendants but that dreadful fate is
the plight of somewhere on earth every
two weeks because on average according
to linguist every fortnight some elder
passes away and carries with them into
the grave the last syllables of an
ancient tongue and the question that is
so haunting is given the fact that this
consensus has been shared by linguists
without really any doubt on their part
for a long time I certainly stumbled
upon it I mean it was really first
brought up by Michael Krause I think was
1992 in his seminal paper academic paper
I can't remember even where it was
published but I think was called the
death of languages I'm you know he was a
woman and then and then Ken Hale at MIT
but no one was screaming about it you
know until you know I came along at the
National Geographic and began to scream
about it because not that I was a
linguist but the fact is that I was
concerned with the erosion of cultural
diversity yes and that the issue of
language lost was something that
audiences could really understand you
know you know you you you could talk
vaguely about the importance of culture
but if you actually said to people how
would you feel if you couldn't pass on
your wisdom to your children you know
that really got people
and you know the reason I mean you know
when people ask me well why didn't
people cry out about the crisis and the
answer really is two words Noam Chomsky
Noam Chomsky was a brilliant linguist he
was also a wonderfully progressive and
remains a wonderfully progressive figure
who's whose credentials as one of the
consistent opponents to Vietnam you know
we're burnished as already formidable
credentials as an academic linguist and
and made him almost on beyond reproach
for good and bad reasons and Chomsky's
original insight was really brilliant he
basically said you know this idea that
languages are acquired by children as a
kind of reward system and a kind of
behavioral sense like Skinner might
report you know that you know Johnny
says I love you dad and gets an Apple
you know as a reward Chomsky I think
really was brilliant and saying that's
ridiculous
he said language acquisition is an
incredibly complex thing and it happens
in all cultures at roughly the same age
and he quite brilliantly said well
there's got to be some kind of
hardwiring we've got to be hardwired as
a species for language acquisition and
what that wiring consisted of was
unclear it wasn't a physical organ like
your heart or lungs but it was like a
cognitive space he hypothesized what he
called a universal grammar that were
whereby people could really make this
extraordinary
adaptation and then acquire language at
the age of two you know walk one talk to
with your father now now that was all
brilliant but the problem was that again
going back to the biological analogy you
know if you are a biologist and you want
to study the origin of life and
molecular biologists what do you study
you studied DNA and you don't really
care if the DNA come
from you know a common fruit fly or rare
panda bear because DNA is basically
consistent right so you go for the fruit
fly because it's easier doesn't mean
that your st. panda bears aren't
important but their survival is in the
realm of conservation biologists or an
ecologist or whatever right
environmentalists I'm focused on the
essence of life DNA and I can get from
fruit flies well in a way Chomsky was
saying the really important thing we
need to understand is the universal
grammar this we need to approach this
cognitive space and try to delineate its
parameters its dimensions through
theoretical inquiry right and and how
that in a way genotype of language if
you will is expressed really doesn't
matter or if it does you know I'm not
interested but the real message was it
doesn't really matter and it got as far
as them saying that to run around the
world trying to document and record the
the syntax the grammar the word list
that vocabularies the dictionaries of
all these dying languages spoken by
fifteen people or a thousand people or
whatever was fundamentally kind of a
waste of time and that was never said
implicit explicitly but it was from
everything I gather from people like
Michael Krause and Ken Hale who was a
colleague of Chomsky at MIT it was kind
of the message Chomsky was just so
powerful and so brilliant and so
politically popular because of his
positions on Vietnam and other
progressive issues that he was kind of
untouchable and so as a linguist friends
said to me I'm not too many years ago if
we had all the money in the world
limitless budget just to document the
dying languages of the world or the
fading languages or the threatened
language is better because I like the
idea that languages never die they just
sleep they can always be
brought back but if we had all the money
in the world to document all the extent
languages of humanity we couldn't do it
because there are literally not enough
linguist trained to do that kind of work
there are millions of linguists trained
to do theoretical work with elements of
language and so on
and and so that the whole the Chomsky
had on the profession for whatever the
theoretical advances that he was able to
inspire and more power to them for that
from everything I understand from
colleagues who are linguists it helped
it held back things for for at least 20
years and then then in 1998 when I came
along and read Michael crosses paper
which I think was 1992 so I was late to
the game and I started to scream about
it for my bully pulpit of the National
Geographic and I was just one of many
voices but in a certain sense a kind of
dam broke it was like the old proverbial
what if the emperor has no clothes and
beginning in the first decade of this
century there was this kind of amazing
tsunami of publications by people like
my friend David Harrison and David
crystal and you know just a slew of
books I've got it now I've got I mean
I've literally got a shelf of books on
language loss Lyle Campbell at
University of Utah was brilliant he's
now at Hawaii you know these these you
know the shelf of books but most of
those got published between 2000 you
know after 2000 in other words there was
a amazing dearth of literature because
it wasn't considered to be important and
then suddenly this new generation came
along of real field linguists who saying
you're damn right it's important and and
now they're there there's been this
really gratifying
you know counter-revolution if you will
where where language revitalisation
documentation is is is Murrow a
wonderful group called
Wiki chunks where a young kid from my I
forget what the school was I think it
was trying to remember what school it
was and in New York State I lectured
gave a guest speech at you know back in
that late 90s and this kid was in the
audience and he just got turned down to
this issue of language he started this
global grassroots thing called wiki
tongues where they send young
backpacking kids all around the world
recording languages you know yeah and
they're getting to be more than as
backpackers highly-skilled young kids
you know that's a really beautiful way
of putting it that the way that we get
to endeavor into consciousness and
express ourselves and communicate with
each other to be able to capture that
those the languages the prior to at the
ethnographic condensation that's
occurring just like we are so passionate
about the biodiversity saving that and
cataloging that and restoring that
revitalizing that to be similarly
passionate about language like that to
understand how the spirit engages the
with the world and with each other
through through language and I also
wanted to say this there's a way that
places like Silicon Valley in the genius
of Engineers and artificial intelligence
actually help with processes like this
which is that there are some cultures
around the world that are beginning to
use indigenous cultures around the world
that are beginning to use voice memos on
their smartphone technology and so to be
able to parse those voice memos using
natural language processing and then be
able to make a power-law distribution of
the most common words used and try and
parse further about
what the words actually mean and get
like you said train more people on
linguistics to be able to assist with
that process and to begin cataloging
through these voice memos that they're
sending each other that's a really great
way to leverage technology for something
like capturing the languages of the
world and then and this may even be the
pressing question of our time is it
maybe the purpose of this reality is
exactly what we're going through right
now this is a very interesting time of
transition that we're going through and
being able to make AI through this you
know I mean I think I think you're right
and since look it's one of the things
that really has helped me in my life is
a quote from Peter Mathewson one of my
favorite writers who said anyone who
thinks they can change the world is both
wrong and dangerous and what he meant
was obviously people like Mao Hitler and
Stalin Pol Pot for that matter didn't
mean that we didn't have an obligation
to bear witness to the world but if you
if you have this expectation that you
know what how the world should be and
you try to impose it on people it almost
never is for the betterment of anyone
and by the same token if you if you get
wrapped up in the latest sort of current
of discouraging news
it doesn't really allow you to stay long
in the game in other words when I was a
young man deeply involved in the
anti-war movement I would get so
disappointed or the environmental
movement if we lost an environmental
battle it was it was it was it was it
could be devastating you know and then I
began to adopt a more or what might
becomes more Buddhist perspective that
you know you're not in it to win you're
in it for the path in other words you're
you you don't have any expectation of
the destination or the goal let alone a
victory you just do it because it's the
right thing to do and that that was
really helpful to me because it didn't
make me any less engaged or any less
effective it just
lowered my expectations in a way that
that reduced exposure to disappointment
in a sense and allowed me to keep going
and you realize that you do this because
it's just what you want to do and it
reminded me of my father who is not a
religious or let alone a Christian
person but he always said to me you know
you know this son there's good and evil
in the world and pick your side and get
on with it
you know we have this sort of thing in
in Christianity that that evil will be
some eventually vanquished by the Christ
child right but that's never going to
happen and it never has happened and
people for example in the Hindu faith
would never expect it to happen I mean
when Lord Krishna was asked the famous
question that caused heretics and evil
France to be burned at the stake you
know if God's all-powerful why does he
allow evil to exist in the universe Lord
Krishna said to thicken the plot in
other words we you know this is the
plastic in the plot and and it's always
going to be there so you know and in
that sense I think you you you can you
can it can help you weather storms like
the one we're going through now where
things seem to be so discouraging we're
a democracy thrives and the truth and
autocracy thrives on lies you know the
bigger the better and we can see this in
in countries like Turkey and Russia and
the United States where we're really the
forces of our door of darkness our
ascendant in some sense but at a deeper
level what we're really seeing I think
is and certainly the United States it
seems to me that they're kind of the the
classic schism between the two halves of
the American reality right now I still
fundamentally come down to whether
you're opposed to or on the side of
these this remarkable set of
social transformations that occurred
beginning in the 1960s and through the
whole process of changed and I mean it's
not just the 1960s of women getting the
birth control pill people changed in
attitudes towards race but I mean you
know whenever the right-wing gets sort
of nostalgic for the 1950s I often
wonder what world they think they lived
in it was an absolutely horrible time if
you were gay if you're a woman if you
were black and it was stultifying even
if you were from a privileged white
upper-class family I mean I can't
imagine how tedious and horrible the
1950s must have been how can confining
and I think a lot of the the classic
kind of divide is is is you know it's
not like the 60s for some kind of golden
era Lord knows we elected Nixon twice
you know more people look like Tricia
Nixon than Joni Mitchell you know but
the point is there was a sea change of
attitudes which for better for worse and
it seems to me a lot of what the divide
is about now those who are comfortable
with those changes fundamentally and
those forgive those changes remain an
incredible threat like even if you look
at the evangelical right I mean one of
the most fascinating things is going on
within the evangelical right in America
right now is how young people from that
world are turning their backs on it in
other words the the the number of young
Millennials who are moving in those
circles is plummeting right even even as
I mean if it means abandoning their
beliefs and their families because
they're there looking around and there's
there they are actually seen evangelical
Christianity as synonymous with the
hypocrisy of Donald Trump and they're
not having any of it so the actual
far-right evangelical right you know
where you can have some like Billy
Graham's son literally say that Donald
Trump is the second coming of Christ I
mean I've heard that I mean I've had
missionaries in the jungles of South
America told me that Henry Kissinger was
a second
I mean of Christ literally in the wake
of the Yom Kippur War that I remember
when that I heard that I thought well
they're two men in the world who now
think that you know we have so many
other topics that I don't want to cover
with you so this is something that's
very near and dear to many of our hearts
so we have the difference between
cultural exchange versus appropriation
and this is something that
anthropologists are trying to figure out
how to do in a way that's harmonious and
there's a couple movements here one of
them is like a fashion anthropology
which we think is very interesting which
is people going in to indigenous
subcultures and understanding how they
harmonize with their environments what
they do with their sacred arts and then
if the indigenous they're you know you
ask and you engage with in their
community you understand the power
balance and dynamic that's happening you
do research on that and then sometimes
you maybe take if they're interested
take and try and spread their messages
of their indigenous subculture around
the world but then you to be able to do
that in a way that's truly harmonious
versus feeling like it's appropriation
so my question about that is you had
something that came up as well for you
with the serpent in the rainbow because
this is interesting you went in trying
to understand Haitian voodoo and try and
share that with the rest of the world
and then sold the rights to Hollywood
who then you said also egregiously yeah
misappropriated it then what do we do
yeah I mean that's it that was a tricky
one because you know my entire mission
was to try to take this religion that
had been used exploded an explicitly
racist way you know I mean the idea that
voodoo was somehow black magic was so
outrageous I mean if I asked you to name
the great religions of the world what
continent do we always leave I would
sub-saharan Africa and of course voodoo
was just the religion of that region of
the world and in the quintessential
democratic faith in which to believer no
noise direct access to the divine but
actually becomes a God which is why
Asians always said to me
you white people go to church and speak
about God we dance some sample and
become God so I really was on a kind of
mission to use a zombie phenomena that
in particular had been used to exploit
the Voot of faith and try to make sense
out of sensation and that's what I
really did try to do in my books and
ironically one of the reasons that we
had this cliche about voodoo who came
from the fact that in the 1920s the US
Marine Corps occupied Haiti and
everybody above the rank sergeant got a
book contract and the books had names
like cannibal cousins Black Baghdad and
they gave rise to the RKO movies of the
40's knighted the Living Dead and so on
which created and perpetuated this
cliche of children bread for the
cauldron zombies crying out of grave to
attack people voodoo dolls and pins and
needles it and so on and then I write
this book and it was well received and
someone wanted to buy the film rights
and the producer was a great friend of
mine to this day David Ladd thought that
he had Peter Weir I was told Peter Weir
would be the director and and a year of
living dangerously was kind of a perfect
prototype for the film so I thought that
was really exciting so I signed away the
rights and with the studio and Peter
we're just done Mosquito Coast it goes
down the line and ends up in Wes
Craven's and even wes is a good guy late
died but Wes wanted to make a real a
picture but by the time the film gets
back to Universal Studios a voodoo
zombies they gussy it up and the film
came out and the way the film although
it's remains very popular was certainly
in my eyes sort of a betrayal of the
sentiment of the book in that very
important way how do we ensure its
cultural exchange what are some mean
principles for anthropologists well I
mean first of all I don't think you know
it's like it it it's we have this idea
that these cultures are so fragile and
delicate they must be protected from us
you know and I think that's an
incredibly conceited patronizing
colonial idea I mean I've spent all of
my life
amongst indigenous people and I've never
had an experience where I wasn't
absolutely certain that if I misbehaved
or offended people or simply was my
presence was no longer required or
desire did they would just tell me to
leave I mean I just this there's a kind
of a precious conceit in this idea that
you know these all these poor people I
find it really repugnant you know and
and and in that sense you know
information and and and cultural
diffusion has always happened you know
you know I I think you know cultural
appropriation is this is a tricky thing
because I'm on the one hand we want the
messages of the elder brothers for
example to spread around the world they
want they feel I mean this idea that
these societies are isolated and I mean
there are certain isolated societies and
they're very very clear issues they're
about how do you how do you make sure
that those societies are not ravaged by
contact or with diseases or exploited or
you know and and no one's got the answer
for that frankly but spiritual awareness
with trying to share what the elder
brother knows with the younger brother
well I mean I mean I think that you know
you talk to the mumbles they want what
they're they want people to be
spokespeople you know I I find I find it
first of all I you know this idea of the
anthropologist going in to study them
it's that's like 50 years out of date no
one does that you know everything I've
ever done I'm a storyteller studying
ourselves we're studying ourselves and
and where we're as a storyteller I tell
stories and I never tell stories without
full collaboration of the people among
whom I'm living as a guest I mean every
film I've ever been made has always been
based on strict protocols and agreements
and compensation
and training and everything else it's
all you know I've the strongest sense
that it you know that it that that it's
about it's not the traditional versus a
modern it's what kind of world do we all
want to live in and in that sense I may
be seen as old-fashioned or blind to
what they like to call my privilege you
know what which is a notion I completely
reject you know I you know I I've been a
storyteller since you know I went off to
South America when I was 19 you know
living on $3 a day on the streets of
South America you know I didn't feel
very privileged much to that time you
know and you know I I think I think
there are issues when you know I mean a
classic example would be ayahuasca you
know it's just gone from this incredibly
obscure traditional sacred potion to
being sort of dispensed on every street
corner by legitimate people and also by
mail-order mystics you know I mean the
international acclaim of ayahuasca just
as shocking to me when I came back from
Colombia in 1975 I mean lived there
15 months on that first trip and taken
ayahuasca in traditional context a
couple three times you know I mean I
could have mentioned the word ayahuasca
known and a million would have heard
Iannone you know and now it's sort of I
just gave a keynote at a conference in
Barcelona with an ayahuasca 2,000 people
there you know you know I mean I think
cultural appropriation ranges from
stealing the Elgin marbles
you know from Greece to an ongoing
serious epidemic of of marketing of rare
treasures through illicit smuggling you
know rings which should be heavily
policed and heavily condemned to more
subtle things but i but I reject the
idea that ever place is a cloak of
fragility and
and and around peoples that are in fact
my experience indescribably strong yeah
this again this gets back to this
fundamental idea you know that you know
what's you know we have this idea that
these cultures quaint and colorful are
sort of destined to fade away as if by
natural laws if their failed attempts of
being modern failed attempts of keeping
up when nothing could be further from
the truth in every cases our dynamic
living people's being driven out of
existence by identifiable forces and
those forces can be ideological think
the cult of modernity the Marxist mania
of Beijing or whatever or they can be
industrial as we well know but the
exciting thing is that if human beings
are actually the if cultural diversity
is being lost by actions of human beings
we can also be the facilitators of
cultural survival that's right and so I
think I think that's where I come down
on on you know it's not a violation
us-versus-them it's about what kind of
world are we all gonna live in where is
our directional arrow pointed and the
preservation and the revival and the law
cataloguing of that is crucial and we
didn't get too deep into psychoactive
but oh my goodness I believe it just
quickly the way that psychedelics and
entheogens play into the evolution of
consciousness and to be I think one of
the most evocative I mean coming yeah I
mean I mean one of the things I find so
fascinating is that when we look at
those sort of social transformations
over the last 40 years that we've
identified you know the role of women
the position of people of color that the
unbelievable fact that gay men and women
can marry inconceivable in my youth
right the the idea that we could really
look at the earth as Gaia you know a
living interactive planet which is what
so threatens the people of the more
traditional far right I mean I mean
these ideas I mean think let me do that
again
I mean the thing that we forget is that
this incredible social transformation
women in a generation going from the
kitchen to the boardroom people of color
from the woodshed to the White House gay
people men and women from the closet to
the altar school children talking of
biodiversity the biosphere of Gaia
people beginning to abandon traditional
patriarchal religion for the for the the
the subtle nuances of the Dharma in
Buddhism which is one of the fastest
growing religions in the West the fact
that we really are seen the earth in
almost metaphysical terms as as a living
entity now the all of the things from
above that I mentioned are profoundly
threatening to someone who isn't
prepared to accept them I mean my gosh
I mean Minh who still hasn't would have
for lack of a better word an
old-fashioned notion of gender roles of
biblical creation of the static you know
I mean people always is Bobby kick
Robert Kennedy always said you know
people always invoke in a style people
who were afraid in the future uncertain
of the present always an invoke of
nostalgia for the past
for a world of the past that never
existed but has to be assumed of existed
to rationalize their fears of today and
tomorrow right and and so people have
been asked to absorb a lot right but
that said when we look at the genesis of
those transformations I find it
fascinating that the one ingredient in
the recipe of social change that is
constantly expunged from the record is
that millions of us lay prostrate before
the gates of all having taken some
psychedelic I don't use drugs I never
really have gotten into marijuana I have
no interest but I took psychedelics and
I'm proud to say that I wouldn't write
the way I write I wouldn't think that
way I think likewise I wouldn't have
understood the nature of cultural
relativism as an anthropologist I
wouldn't treat women the way I do our
parents used to say don't take these
things you'll never come back the same
that was a whole bloody point right and
so so so I I think that the one of the
very positive things going on today it's
a very judicious and cautious at feels
cautious revitalization of the use of
psychedelics and finally the recognition
that these substances can be legitimate
tools for clinical use in certain cases
and for research so so I mean I all this
stuff is moving ahead it's just it's not
going to be smooth because the the
changes that we're endorsing are
profoundly unsettling to those not
prepared to recognize and the fact that
the genies out of the bottle ain't going
back and the tsunami of social change
and transformation and spiritual growth
and reinvention of our entire sense of
ourselves in the planet it's rolling
forward and you know get out of the way
if you're not prepared because it'll
drown you if you're not prepared to
float upon it yeah the awakening is
happening with a myriad of tools and
that transition we are going to succeed
in I'm very proud that that collectively
the awakening is happening given the
timeliness of the time of transition I
mean it's just it's so beautiful and we
thank you very much for coming on the
program well thanks that's been fun it's
been such an honor I really appreciate
you Beth thanks for making the effort
and I look forward to our future
conversations I know that you have a you
have an upcoming book that we didn't get
to but that we will potentially later
when when it does come up Magdalene a
river of dreams it's your love story to
Columbia yeah I mean you know Columbia
deserved its Agony's you know it's it's
a it's worth just pointing out before we
go that how would America feel if
Canada's patterns of drug consumption
and its laws which did not curb that
consumption but facilitated black-market
in that set of drugs resulted in 85
million Americans 85 million Americans
being driven from their homes well
that's what happened in Colombia most
Colombians have never seen cocaine used
cocaine and the engine that's been
driving the entire conflict in Colombia
is cocaine and the engine that drives
the production and consumption of
cocaine is consumption that's the engine
and so everybody you know who uses
cocaine has a blood of Colombian people
on their hands Wow that's going to be a
wild book yeah and we talked about this
before we're starting but the importance
of writing with the with the passion for
Awakening something that's going to
leave a big mark on on awakening Wow
I asked this question a lot on the
program so I'm curious just hear quick
thoughts on it does it feel like
humanity is a biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence I'm not sure
what that means does it feel like we're
all building super intelligence or
general intelligence that that's our
destiny to build now I the very thought
terrifies me the very thought terrified
you know and why because it's abundantly
clear that we have lost our ability to
to monitor and control even
the initial wave of transformation that
the digital frontier is allowed us you
know Facebook Twitter I mean six
basically six billionaires in Silicon
Valley have within their hands the
ability to protect or frankly destroy
our democratic traditions that have
developed in such a powerful way but
always on by definition of fragile
foundation you know the minute the
minute that that truth no longer is
grounded in reality that people can
invent their own realities that's a
that's a terrifying terrifying frontier
not a place I ever want to live yet to
be able to take deep spiritual moral
ethical philosophical roots and embed
them into the exponential technology age
is paramount and we need to do that with
greater vigor moving forward imagine
defending defending using the language
of free speech to defend individuals who
are prepared to get on a public podium
and lie or promote the most horrific of
aberrant behaviors to compromise to
compromise all the dreams of our
forefathers and to allow that to happen
for profit and to use the gloss of
freedom of speech to defend your
personal desire for maintaining a flow
of profits as opposed to proper
responsibilities just important if we
don't get the top of the hierarchy of
Prof people the 1500 billionaires at the
top the ones that own the corporation
sixth over six I would start with six
men in Silicon Valley
yeah forget about the 15 and government
leaders in general yet that the
government leaders have no role in it
then
they're not doing anything well she
shouldn't being Vladimir Putin I mean
these are just period I mean don't
trumpets edram but then also just the
top like you said these top six
billionaires but the irony there I was
just saying that just in general just
the getting those top people having
feelings of ego loss or interconnected
well that's not going to happen that's
like asking for empathy from Hitler but
the point is that you can point to these
global leaders but we can't control
Putin we can't control XI but we've
we're talking now about six Americans in
Silicon Valley who have in their hands
the capacity to tame the Internet and to
truly eliminate it as a place where
truth does not matter and those six men
have a responsibility and if they turn
their backs on it then the problems the
internet will have died in their
lifetimes yeah now they are voting there
are Americans they are Californians yeah
yeah forget about Putin any weekend yeah
anyway your focus on that I love that um
okay that's it that's that's that's a
wrap okay good thank you
thank you thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode let us know true thinking
on all of the different things that wade
was teaching us let us know your
thoughts in the comments below also
check out the links in the bio blow to
Wade's work check out those links go
watch his films on his website please go
watch those they are so profoundly
awakening go and check those out and
support his other works please also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders organizations in
your communities and around the world
that you believe in support them and
help them flourish help the collective
awakening happen support them please and
help them grow you can find all of our
links to our show in the bio below you
can support us as well so you continue
doing cool things like coming on site to
interview great people like wait and go
and manifest that next world everyone
let's get there together we love you
very much thanks for tuning in and we'll
see you soon
peace
it's a sweet man that's it you're so
nice that's it it's so nice to see the
way you're doing this
[Music]
you
[Music]